chaque ville de france a mis en place
des mesures pour réussir son
déconfinement va faire le point à
bordeaux ce matin à 2 km de bouchons sur
la rocade mais un peu plus de voitures
sur les grandes artères du centre ville
un peu plus de monde également dans les
rues et dans les transports en commun
elles des masques et du gel
hydroalcoolique sont distribués avant de
monter ou de sortir des transports une
mobilisation qui permet le respect des
mesures beyrière une reprise en toute
sécurité saluée par le directeur de
bordeaux métropole sur les lignes de
tramway qui passent là on a maintenant
un tram toutes les 7 minutes 30
imaginez donc c'est on est en nette
augmentation par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu dans le compliment et idem pour le
bus on a réouvert des lignes et
augmenter l'offre ce qui permettent
d'avoir un meilleur confort et une
meilleure distanciation pour les
passagers ensuite vous aurez observé que
dans le jeu sur les bus et sur les rames
de tram il ya de la signalétique la
signalétique en eau des portes
d'abord qui incite à laisser sortir les
passagers avant dehors
très la signalétique qui rappelle les
gestes barrière et le port du masque
obligatoire dans les temps des
transports publics à compter
d'aujourd'hui
et on a aussi une face à la mairie de
bordeaux qui a rendu obligatoire le port
de masques aux abords des stations de
métro de tramways et de bus donc c'est
une mesure qui renforce la la sécurité
et l'hygiène du public et des mesures
également rassurante pour les passagers
du tramway est écouté aujourd'hui ça
s'est bien passé il y avait pas beaucoup
de monde tout le monde avait un masque
donc pour l'instant ça va personnes
étaient assis à côté donc pour l'instant
ça va
je trouvais qu'il y avait un petit peu
plus de monde que précédemment bon la
robe n'était pas plein mais il y avait
quand même un tout petit peu nous mais
sinon ça est fait moi j'ai trouvé que
les gens avaient la plupart j'ai fait
que deux personnes qui avait pas de
masque tout le monde à les masquer et il
respecte bien les mesures sanitaires que
tbm à installer donc je suis à moitié
rassuré parce qu'on est quand même
nombreux dans le tram 1
les distances étaient respectées tout le
monde avait des masques les personnes
qui donnent avait pas il ya des
personnes qui se charge de leur
randonnée killer désinfecter les mains
donc non plutôt satisfaite de ce début
de déconfinement et le respect des
règles dans le tramway sur tout